One of the best things about being a fan of
Jason Statham is that he instantly improves
any movie he's in, good, bad, or somewhere
in-between.
The magnetic British action star has been
cracking skulls and delivering delightfully
hammy lines for over two decades.
Whether he's a snarling villain or a hardened
hero, Statham has turned in dozens of extremely
enjoyable performances since he was first
introduced as part of Guy Ritchie's repertory
of British toughs in the late nineties.
If you're even a casual enjoyer of Statham's
work, then you've probably seen him in The
Transporter and Crank, and also as part of
the impressive ensembles in the Expendables
and Fast & Furious franchises.
You've probably even caught his surprisingly
effective comedic work in movies like Spy
and Gnomeo & Juliet.
But there are some movies in the actor's oeuvre
that only hardcore stans of Statham are likely
to have seen.
Enter one of Netflix's current top 10 most
watched movies: the 2013 action movie Homefront.
There's a good chance the name isn't ringing
any bells, as despite some obvious draws,
like James Franco playing a character named
Gator, Winona Ryder as a hardened criminal,
and of course, Statham himself, the movie
never made much of a splash.
"Whatever you're thinking… rethink it."
But as so many films have in the past, it's
getting another life thanks to Netflix.
Here's what you need to know about this overlooked
Jason Statham action thriller.
After a violent drug raid gone bad and the
loss of his wife, DEA Agent Phil Broker decides
to take his daughter, Maddy and retire in
what he believes will be a quiet Louisiana parish.
Unfortunately, it's not long before Broker
learns that not all of his new neighbors are
interested in rolling out the welcome wagon.
After an altercation with some schoolyard
bullies, Broker and Maddy land on the radar
of local meth kingpin Gator, his desperately
addicted sister, Cassie, and his vicious right-hand
woman, Sheryl.
What starts as a game of intimidation quickly
escalates when Gator learns that Broker isn't
just some new guy in town, but a retired DEA
agent, and Broker decides to put his old job
skills to work to try and dismantle Gator's
operation.
Both sides find themselves entrenched in a
violent back and forth.
Broker may be outnumbered, but when Gator
and Sheryl orchestrate the kidnapping of Maddy,
he taps into a well of fury that the small
town criminals couldn't have understood the depths of.
Unfortunately for them, now that they've crossed
the line, there's no going back.
"Here's what you need to know, Broker -- you
have got my attention, son."
Statham has rarely met a group of fictional
malicious criminals who he hasn't wanted to
kick the dirt out of, but when it comes to
Homefront, there was another big pull that
helped bring him on board.
The movie was written by Statham's Expendables
co-star and Oscar nominated screenwriter Sylvester
Stallone.
As Statham told Den of Geek,
"He's one of the great writers.
I think people forget how many great films
he's written.
You know, he wrote Cliffhanger, he wrote all
of the Rockys, all of the Rambos, all of the Expendables films.
It's like a library of mega-success."
In fact, when Stallone first wrote the script
-- which is based on a novel of the same name
by Chuck Logan -- he intended to star in it
himself.
When it came time to actually make the movie,
however, the legendary action star tapped
Statham to take his place.
While speaking with Den of Geek, Statham said
that getting the call was, quote, "one of
the biggest privileges you can get… a hand-delivered
script for something [Stallone] wrote for himself."
Critics also found plenty to enjoy in the
movie, which was summed up by many as simple
but satisfying.
Noah Berlatsky, writing for The Atlantic,
said that
"As a big dumb action movie, it works pretty
well.
[...] Overall, Homefront delivers the enjoyment
you'd expect from a shoot-‘em-up."
Manohla Dargis of The New York Times summed
up the experience of watching Homefront by
calling it "indefensibly enjoyable."
Andy Lea of the Daily Star said
"Nobody can write this stuff quite like Stallone.
And nobody from this over-drama schooled,
over-Botoxed generation of movie stars can
play it like Statham."
You can judge for yourself by checking out
Homefront on Netflix.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.